and every guy sees the first to arrive
where is pragnananda
just around 10 seconds left before the
clocks begin and they will start the
clocks on the dot that's how it works at
the feed day World Cup pregnant arriving
late and there's only three minutes on
the clock you cannot afford
[Music]
no the clocks begin where is Prague
this is crazy this has never been seen
before we've seen Magnus Carlsen arrive
later games but this is even higher
stakes and unforgiving
and there we go it is handshake practice
lost 30 seconds 30 valuable seconds on
the clock
White's about to make a new Queen and
Arjun offers his hand after all of that
pragnananda is the one to win
[Music]
thank you